they got [ __ ] at sam's and scott that's
nice yeah i know
hey are we on we on there yeah i think
we're on already
i don't even know you press the button
well yeah it's it's almost three o'clock
it's like only a few minutes still and
we had a few people waiting so i'm
i might as well like i said i'm sorry
it's lagging again i
um i actually bought a
what do you call it an ethernet cable so
that'll be here in a few days
and we were just talking about maybe
buying a new laptop that's just for
streaming
because this one that we're streaming on
it's a mac and i love it but it's
really old yeah so i don't know if it's
like an issue with the graphics card
because we were live streaming for a
long time
and it was fine and then all of a sudden
just one day it started lagging and now
it's like it does it every time and
she's
kind of driving me bananas she uses the
mac really for just graphic design work
yeah because i have all the programs and
then we have a pc over here that we use
for other stuff
that i use for other things data spacing
and stuff and video i do video editing
but we could just get a you know [ __ ]
microsoft laptop like 300 bucks
that's good enough that's just because
since we're going to be doing it all
right you know
so often though yeah and then she can
dedicate this one just for
lives just for uh graphic design and
this one for video editing and then
we'll have one
live stream i'll just have like five
computers right well that's
i think that's kind of normal now it is
i actually have an oh i have an even
older mac laptop over there that still i
kept it because it has like um
some old backup [ __ ] and it has like all
my music on it
still yeah like that my phone so i just
kind of have it tucked over there yeah
everybody's here
hey you guys deborah mango badger
tammy joy alex oracle mom
pat hatfield's in saul hernandez toy joy
yeah yeah it's yeah most of you guys
were here with us last night
as as we drunkenly went on into the
night
yeah we're gonna [ __ ] review this
documentary georgio has always said that
this documentary is [ __ ] long it was
long
yeah yeah i didn't realize well okay now
our history with this
now this is not the one because we love
oliver harper yeah okay like movie
retrospective
oliver harper go check him out um he
does like really
intricate um retrospectives of
movies like all usually movies from the
80s usually real high quality
usually yeah right and i mean and and i
love that he talks about like every
aspect of it he talks about the score he
talks about the video game tie-ins he
talks about
the special effects he talks about
everything he's like really really well
done
so i think it was his production company
that did a documentary about 80s action
movies
which was called in search of the last
action hero or something like that right
did we see that no i didn't see it yet
okay so we didn't see that
so then we heard that there was another
one coming out that was all about 80s
horror and i was like oh i'm so there
for that
now i don't think um oliver didn't like
direct this one
but i think it's still his production
company you know
yeah because i think it's like a
different i think the guy's name is
david weiner that
uh wrote and or wrote directed it rather
so this was another one that we had been
wanting to see it
and for a long time the only way you
could see it
was if you had given to their
kickstarter or their indiegogo
yeah like it was exclusive like so you
would send me a blue so they would send
you a blu-ray and a poster and all this
other stuff so it was like
you know so it was like limited edition
because we wanted to get one but of
course you know by the time we found out
about it like the kickstarter the
indiegogo were over
um and all of them were gone so i was
like really bummed out and i couldn't
see it and then
a couple of days ago i was uh checking
shutter for
new stuff as i do every up every couple
of days
and lo and behold it was yeah
they got it on shutter so i was super
happy yeah we were [ __ ] jacked about
seeing it i liked it
i yeah i thought it was an excellent
documentary
my only complaint was is that it's too
[ __ ] long
well it could be different up into three
episodes
but you just start it's just overload it
starts to become kind of repetitive
yeah i guess i didn't really find that
because i was like so jacked about
seeing it and it's like i didn't realize
like until we were like kind of started
watching it and then i was like oh my
god this thing is like almost it was
like five hours almost like five hours
it's like five hours long just looking
ridiculous
and i mean we started it fairly early
like in the evening so it's like i just
sat there and watched the whole thing
because i don't give a single [ __ ]
right you know what i mean i i really
enjoyed it actually i didn't get bored
but you know i love
i love horror movies it was it was an
excellent documentary
like i said i would re-edit it into a
mini series
you know make it into a five-part
episode one hour each maybe yeah like a
series okay
like a series like like they did with
like the toys that made us or
something like that exactly that's how i
would do it i guess i could see that but
i mean the thing is you could take it in
pieces
well you can watch it like that if you
wanted to anyway because it does have
what how they um
put it together which i kind of liked
was that
they just went like year by year so they
started in 1980 and then they just kind
of talked about you know whatever the
trends were
in horror movies that year they talked
about you know they talk to filmmakers
they talk to actors and stuff like that
they're in films
and then they like would highlight a few
films that came out that that were
particularly significant or were
particularly
and so it was like really really well
done in that way and they got interviews
with like
everybody man it's like that everybody
was on this [ __ ]
like john carpenter was on there larry
cohen was on there it's just like this
everybody was on there yep
um stuart gordon and it's like uh
although i have to say
i think the mvp of this
documentary was tom [ __ ] atkins
that dude is so funny and like they
they interviewed him i guess like
because you know he was in a [ __ ] ton of
you know john carpenter films and
in a bunch of other ones that they were
talking about so
they interviewed him like a bunch of
times or they had snippets of interviews
with him like a bunch of times and he
was just
i don't i don't even i can't even
explain but it's just like every time
he was on i was just like yeah
you're the best yeah it's a good
documentary like i said
just there's no way you're going to get
me to sit for five hours and watch
anything
i get that like i said it didn't bother
me in the least like i had a cocktail i
was just like like i said
i can watch horror movies or read horror
novels for just hours and hours and
hours at a time and be perfectly content
i'd recommend the average guy take it in
pieces
if you have add yeah it's not evd
just as other [ __ ] going on you know
what i mean come on you know
five hours of talking about horror
movies i could probably handle it about
two
maximum yeah yeah but uh i
i'd take this in two or three pieces
it's good documentary
it's really well put together and like i
said they really did get
a lot of um you know a lot of interviews
and like a lot of really good
clips and they talked about a [ __ ] ton
of movies and not just
the real popular ones that you would you
know they they kind of highlighted a few
that were kind of lesser known but were
significant in other
you know respects also i'm really happy
that in the 1983 segment
they actually talked about the hunger
because i feel like
that movie kind of gets forgotten about
a little bit
you know what i mean well no i yeah
i didn't i never forgot it i know but
some younger people might forget well i
feel like when i see horror
documentaries even ones that are about
vampire movies say or about 80s horror
it seems like it doesn't really get
mentioned a whole lot even though
it's a [ __ ] rad ass movie they don't
talk about cat people much either
that's true they did talk about cat the
remake of cat people the one with
malcolm mcdowell and natasha
natasha kinski yeah yeah um which i just
watched that not too long ago i forgot
how fun that movie was
it's so sordid yeah with all the incest
yeah well that was part of it what's
funny is that you know for the time
the time was a lot more decadent than we
did people think it was back then you
know i didn't even think that was all
that weird
back in the 80s i guess i didn't think
it was all that weird either i mean
because the thing about it is that i
grew up
there's a bunch of weird [ __ ] going on
right well i grew up reading you know
um you know watching horror movies and
also reading [ __ ] like uh
you know flowers in the attic like that
andrew's novels like
which is all incest like brother sister
so it's like it was kind of like ew
but also wasn't really that big a deal i
guess
in the mainstream media mainstream
entertainment there was like
incest fetish [ __ ] horror slash
porn i feel like they're still incest
porn
that's like a big movies there's a lot
of movies that were like that
i mean isn't incest porn still kind of a
big thing nowadays
i don't know i mean after everything
after
there's a porn for everything i know but
i'm just saying isn't that like one of
the more mainstream
ones i don't know i've i thought that
was my perception anyway but it's not
yeah and the thing about it is like when
you're watching the porn it's like oh
it's incest those people aren't really
related
they're just like they're pretending and
i don't know if it was really like was
it like that in the original movie
uh no not that i remember it was the
only way they could avoid from turning
into a damn cat they were yeah cats
the original they weren't even really
guessing i guess you could say weren't
even really humans
yeah they were like monsters like
werewolves except
with cats yeah the original now i
haven't seen the original
uh the val luton one from the 40s like
for a long time
it's a it's a good it's a classic though
but from what i remember the plot of
that one
was that it wasn't a brother and sister
it was just her
you know what i mean and she was like a
shape-shifter so when she got
um and then like she met a dude and
but when she got sexually aroused
inconveniently she would turn into a cat
and like tear your face off
yeah so you know well there was a lot of
you know
anne rice vampire stuff was kind of
weird like that too you know what i mean
she was always
into the gay vampire angle but they
weren't gay because they weren't humans
they were vampires
and they weren't having sex anyway and
they were kind of like
ever they they were just like would jump
on anybody so i feel like it wasn't even
yeah they didn't have sex remember
right they were just uh
that was just part but it was her fetish
porn really is what she was writing for
herself
well yeah because she also wrote she
also wrote those
um i don't know did you know did you
know that she wrote like a whole
um other like softcore porn series like
under a different name
a um layer something like that but she
had like a
a pen name and she wrote like what the
[ __ ] were those books called sleeping
beauty kind of because they were like
fairy tales but they were like dirty
i didn't say i think i only read one of
those because i'm i've never really been
into like
um even when i was a kid i was never
really into like romance kind of [ __ ] or
like
i like erotica like it in small doses
but
i mean ever since i was a kid i was just
like even the scary [ __ ] i just like i
like horror
so but there was that so i i didn't
actually know because like i said i was
interested to see
how much i mean the funding for this
[ __ ] documentary
was they had a kickstarter campaign and
made almost a hundred thousand pounds
on that [ __ ] and then they moved to
indiegogo
and made like 230 000 pounds
so they made like quite a bit of money
on on this but like i said
you know they they had like a limited
number
of blu-rays they had like a whole
package it was really nice that they
would send out to you if you were a
backer like over a certain amount
and like i said i was really bummed that
when i found out that we couldn't get
one because we did look it up but
so i'm just really happy that shutter
added it so i can watch it for free
yes sandra just mentioned you know
imagine you know imagine blue lagoon you
couldn't make blue lagoon today
i you know what blue lagoon even kind of
skeeved me out back then i have to
say and wasn't there another one wasn't
it called pretty baby pretty baby yeah
that was almost basically like what that
was like kitty porn like childhood
yeah it definitely wasn't that i mean
brook shields was what [ __ ] 12
yeah and i think she was 12 and then
yeah there was like nude scenes in that
yeah it was messed up i mean you know it
was just
the times yeah you could get away with
it back then
it was it was subversive and you could
get away with it
yeah i don't know people didn't think it
through or think anything out i don't
think back then either
yeah you know they just didn't think of
the implications they just did things
you know that's a good way just make a
movie you know put that girl in there
she put her naked as well
in there it's fine yeah well it was kind
of like those italian directors
yeah cut that monkey's head off on
camera yeah it's like they didn't
really think of like the gravity of the
whole situation they were just like
whatever we're just going to cut the top
of that monkey's head off it'll look
great
yeah they just did well you know they
were kind of degenerate you know
i just didn't think
let's kill this big giant turtle yeah
just cut that turtle alive yeah that's
awesome okay
keep going yeah we're filming that they
were just you know real life gore
yeah degenerates is what they were well
yeah and you [ __ ] degenerate
[ __ ] they just were in their
own little bubble they didn't think
about it they just did it
yeah yeah i think people were like that
maybe
you know maybe maybe all that unleaded
gasoline [ __ ]
coming out of those damn pipes that's
your lead theory again
like i said let it gasoline i think that
you might be on to something i think so
because man look
i know about mechanics i can build
engines and [ __ ] understand
combustion and
if you put lead particles in gasoline
and send that through an engine
yeah it might kind of help you seal the
valves a little bit but you don't really
need that nowadays
quiet an engine down but those lead
particles come out of the back of that
damn tailpipe
where are they going to go they're going
to blow all around in the damn city and
pile up and
they're going to be trapped in kind of
urban landscapes it's going to ever
be breathing breathing in and it's going
to like eat your brain everybody knows
that [ __ ] lead makes you stupid as
[ __ ]
makes you crazy yeah so i think there's
a lot i think there was something to
that then they quietly kind of got rid
of leaded gasoline
you noticed that yeah over they just
kind of quietly got rid of leaded
gasoline never
made it be a big deal about it it just
it was if all the pumps had it and then
yeah gas station and half the pumps had
it
and then out of six pumps eventually
there might only be one pump that had it
and then it was gone yeah they didn't
[ __ ] say anything about it yeah
it was conspiracy yeah conspiracy
we're just gonna put that everybody
there we're just not gonna let it
ghastly in a way
maybe they knew something i think they
[ __ ] did
and i think that's why there was all
that weird romanesque
[ __ ] serial killer [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] child island [ __ ] men running
around everything yeah where is making
everyone deranged
deranging people i think i mean they're
still like crazy [ __ ] nowadays
but it's just
i don't throw more of them back it
doesn't seem the same you know what i
mean
look at the crime rates the crime people
talk about how violent it is now now man
it was a lot more violence
the crime rate started well yeah the
crime rate actually started uh
really going down a lot in the 90s
that's about the time that damn leaded
gasoline started yeah
disappear i mean there's spikes every
now and then late 80s let it
leaded gasoline was going away yeah when
the 90s were around that was gone
i think that's around the time the
[ __ ] crime rate started to drop
yeah i think like the if i'm remembering
correctly i think like despite like the
highest point of like number of serial
killers like known zero killers was
either 1987 or 1989
yeah and um and then after that like in
the beginning of the 90s it just like
the crime rate like fell
yeah and here's something to [ __ ]
blow your mind the romans ate lead
yeah they drank out of lead pipes they
seasoned their food with lead
lead dust and their little [ __ ]
plates were made out of lead that they
ate off of expensive plate was lead
yeah and as crazy as those [ __ ] were
i'm telling you there's a link there
they're not telling us yeah like i said
it might not be the only factor but
it would it would really shock me if it
wasn't a pretty significant i think the
damn fuel companies realized that they
might have been liable for some of that
[ __ ] and they quietly got rid of all
that and that's how they got rid of the
they avoided a bunch of lawsuits of
course because the elites the richest
people in the [ __ ] society were doing
that
putting lead in the gasoline yeah
[Laughter]
because that just sounds like a [ __ ]
good idea doesn't it
leslie russell said psycho ended the
gothic monsters era and started the
slasher genre yes it did also
another movie that i feel like doesn't
get um
the same amount of attention as psycho
is peeping tom
which came out the same year as psycho
um
it was a british movie and the weird
thing about it is that
it was one of the first it was very much
like a slasher in the sense that
the guy was a serial killer and he had
like a
he was like a photographer and he would
he would stab the women like with this
spike thing that he had
on the camera so he could not only take
a picture of them as they were dying but
also he had a mirror on there so they
could watch themselves being murdered
because he got off it's called peeping
tom and it came out in 1960
and i feel like it's it doesn't get
mentioned in the same breath of psycho
even though it came out in the same year
and it was
also like really influential like in the
slasher genre
um and it actually the director i can't
remember what his name is
uh at the moment like i know what it is
but i can't think of it right now
and it like ruined his career yeah
because nobody made movies like that in
1960 i mean that was super ahead of
the curve and that came out and everyone
was just like horrified
because it was like well it was because
it was from it's
much like psycho is it's almost like
made you sympathize
with the killer right and some people
just could not handle that [ __ ]
um you know they didn't want them to
seem like they didn't want you to have
to like
feel sorry for a monster or relate to a
monster or
you know just even follow him the haze
code haze code or hague's code whoops
it's haze hazeco actually said you
couldn't do that
you could that all evil doers had to be
punished in movies
yeah there was that for a long time i
don't even remember when the haze code
was lifted
um it must have been before psycho came
out though i would think
wasn't it i don't know i don't remember
all that but yeah because
yeah that if you were a bad guy you had
to
be killed or be killed or arrested at
the end you couldn't just like not get
away with it
you're right which is funny to me it's
like because
in real life that [ __ ] happens all the
time but well it made sense because
hollywood was under investigation for a
bunch of anti-american
stuff michael powell thank you yeah i
knew if i couldn't think of it you guys
want to [ __ ] just find something
interesting man there's a
there have been movies i don't know if
they've been disappeared or not but they
were kind of like the history of
hollywood who's
who started all the uh um the the
studios in the early
1900s what their political alignment was
there was a lot of them were more
marxist and were kind of like
uh um supporting the bolshevik
revolutions in in
uh in in russia at that time they
started to get up
getting scrutinized for like
anti-american activity
and they were doing stuff that caused
the government to pass the haze code
and then when world war ii happened
the hollywood kind of joined the army in
a certain way
they became part of the military
industrial complex to help them
with the war effort and that's really
kind of when hollywood
kind of formed an alliance with the
government and it was a government
propaganda mouthpiece all throughout the
world war ii
era and after world war ii was over
it was hollywood's job was to
reintegrate and reincorporate all these
damn [ __ ] battle-hardened veterans
into society
so they had all these rules you know
what i mean they were trying to get
these guys coming back from war to
become civilized again and they were
pumping up american traditional american
values about family life and
living in the suburbs and yeah and it
was you know
darren and samantha and [ __ ]
bewitched and you know they were doing
all that
you know leave it to be that was all
government propaganda
most people mostly wanted to live like
that but a lot of people couldn't live
like that
but the country was becoming more
suburban
and uh eventually that [ __ ] got stale
back in the 60s and the 70s and really
didn't
60s movies didn't a lot of most of them
didn't look like the 1960s that was in
la la land
and it started to [ __ ] wither and die
it wasn't until the 80s there was a
rebirth with all the damn
guys that you know today you know lucas
and spielberg and all that and they kind
of revived hollywood
now those guys are dying off hollywood
hollywood in a way that we know it won't
survive
not all this pandemic and all this [ __ ]
and it's technologically obsolete it
lasted for about 100 years
that's about how long it's going to last
it's going to
all be independent films from here on
out and foreign films and
hollywood as you know it as we knew it
is gone anyway it's not there it's
spread out over the united all over the
united states
it's this i don't even think really the
studios exist anymore
physically do they some of them do some
of them do
but they're not in hollywood i think
they're in other states aren't they
no they're still there yeah okay as far
as i know because i know they
mostly don't film there anymore i heard
it was mostly a tourist attraction
yeah a lot of the movies aren't shot
there um they shoot a lot of movies in
toronto
they should i mean especially if they're
like
and i just don't think it television
really put a hurting on it
and now internet and uh
there'll be movies but not as you know
them i don't think like you said it's
more independent which like i said it's
fine
um and xanada says atlanta is big for
filming movies yeah they film a lot of
stuff in georgia right uh nowadays to tv
and movies
um but what i was trying to say is that
that's not hollywood
yeah hollywood is in california it's a
little [ __ ] town
that's gone they're not filming there
yeah you know they're
and so it's been busted up
and you know i think disney probably
soon evidently disney's going through
huge layoffs
they lost their asses on star wars and
their [ __ ] stream in service and
now they're not making any money through
uh disney world and disneyland
disney's gonna go into a shell for a
while i bet you disney's going to be
on life support for the next five years
that's my exam that's that's what i'm
predicting but we'll see
yeah uh oracle said psycho was actually
uh you know made in 1960 but
the haze code didn't end until eight
years later in 1968
so [ __ ] man how the [ __ ] they get around
that because they even showed a toilet
they even showed a toilet in psycho and
they weren't
technically allowed to do that that was
like the first one to do it another
thing i wanted to comment on too was
somebody said um
about john carpenter um kind of not
ripping off but being uh influenced by
psycho
you know for the slasher genre i also
wanted to mention too
that one of the first slasher movies
yes black christmas from 1974 but there
was an earlier one than that it was
italian and it was called may of blood
that one had or twitch of the death
nerve was mario bava
and it is i saw it not too long ago
because i've been hearing about
how it was like one of the like the
proto-slasher and i could not believe
how slasher-like it was and i think that
was from 1968 or 1969
had the killer pov like you know the
naked people in the lake like getting
murdered and stuff like that the only
thing that was not slasher-like was
who the killer ended up being um but
other than that
it had very very similar so i almost
feel like the slasher movies of the 80s
were more influenced by the italian
movies like giallo movies
than maybe they even were by hitchcock
because it was a combination of the two
things because in the early 80s they
were playing those italian slasher films
on cinemax and hbo
yeah yeah so everybody was seeing them
there was a good response and that's the
way you really wanted to go
but getting back to the [ __ ] whole
hollywood angle there were really only
two real
real good eras of this whole thing and
that was
the golden era which is what the 30s
right yeah and then the 80s
the rest of those eras weren't all that
good and that's really what this
documentary was about it kind of points
out how good the 80s were
for film they're real good well because
you it was kind of like the same
in music too like a lot of the kind of
wheels came off
and kind of you could do anything yeah
and i feel like
and one of the things that they were
talking about in the documentary was
that the 80s was kind of like the age
particularly in the horror genre was
like the age of like the special effects
people as like rock stars
yeah and like because people wanted to
see the movies just to see
like what the gore effects were going to
be what the special effects were going
to be like
and um so that was kind of cool too
because i've always really been into
like tom savini and all that other kind
of
um that whole special effects stuff that
whole decade
not only for horror but for sci-fi and
then the crossovers between horror
sci-fi
with an action [ __ ] was [ __ ] awesome
just awesome yeah that was the the
second golden age
now it did kind of go into the 90s but
it wasn't as good
if you asked me the 90s i kind of like
like honestly
the 70s and the 80s i feel like we're
like the golden era particularly in
horror and sci-fi
yeah um once it went into the 90s it
just it got a little too
slick for me yeah particularly like
horror movies because
it kind of went into a thing where
everyone it was like the 90210 of horror
yeah and it's like it really nothing was
like gritty or some of the [ __ ] was good
some of it was some of the [ __ ] some of
it was i'm not saying that it's like
there's no decade that's like a complete
and total loss there's always good
there's always a few good things here
and then it's just that the 80s
everything is [ __ ] real
natural and creative like look here's a
good example
okay i'm gonna go back to predator one
all right nowadays these [ __ ]
hollywood losers are constantly going on
about [ __ ] well we're gonna have to
have
this kind of representation and we have
to have a diverse cast and we have to
have [ __ ] this for a woman the
female it's just so artificial
when you looked at [ __ ] predator one
that was a diverse cast every one of
them guys was pretty much a different
race and there was a one there was women
soldiers in it too but it happened so
naturally you didn't realize it
it just seemed like a normal story
because that's the way
military situations looked if they were
to do that now it would look
fake as [ __ ] it's because they they try
hard too much
you know what i mean yeah the hollywood
directions you don't you don't have
you don't really know what i'm talking
about i guess right like it's to me
in the summer i know you're talking
about but it's like it's not so [ __ ]
fake and artificial today i know i don't
know i guess it just doesn't occur to me
i just watched a [ __ ] movie you know
it just looks [ __ ] fake the way
everything is like
the superhero movies and it's like
very forced it doesn't seem natural
uh they did everything everything that
hollywood tries to be
today they did naturally back in the 80s
to an extent i think it was just natural
to an extent
that's just my opinion that's my take on
it yeah that's my take on it that's how
that's the tone of those movies um
it just seemed very analog and very
naturalistic
everything that they did it see today
the [ __ ] they do just seems
forced fake and [ __ ] political you
know it's like it's a political agenda
but it wasn't back then yeah mango
badger said the remake of the blob from
1988 is
great and better than the original i
actually happen to agree with you on
that
and they do actually talk about that uh
on in search of darkness as well uh a
little bit like i said
because they because it's so you know
they talk about so many movies
they don't go like super super in depth
into any
just anyone but they do cover like
a lot of ground and the blob was
definitely one that they
talked about and i remember i haven't
seen it in a long time
but um i remember really really because
it's how [ __ ] gross it is and the
special effects
especially like the one person that gets
like sucked into the sink drain or
whatever and then like the one that's
like
uh you know that the blob just gets and
they're all like [ __ ] torn apart like
that i mean it looks fantastic it still
looks fantastic
and i always said that you know if you
did good special effects back in the 80s
like watch the [ __ ] thing watch an
american werewolf in london watch
anything like that that [ __ ] still looks
good
because they knew what they were doing
and it was real it was really there
whereas if you use cgi it's gonna date
in a few years you know what i mean and
it never
and i'm not saying that it won't look
good at some point in the future like
it'll get
so good that you won't be able to tell
the difference but they're not
at that point yet i mean yeah it looks
good and sometimes you can't tell
but it still looks a little bit off it's
still a little uncanny valley
yeah dj maniac saying that the thing had
a diverse cast too but not as diverse as
the predator
yeah the [ __ ] the whole cast of the
thing was awesome it was all
dudes which that that checks out for
that era you know
some on antarctica it would all be dudes
in that [ __ ] thing
uh but they were all different they're
all different personalities so
it was a great cast and then santa says
uh same thing was an alien it was all
the characters were very natural
yeah and then the alien cast where they
were all
all those um crew members the on the
script that were written to be
either sex it didn't matter they were
kind of unisex and they just cast
people to fit them and it just did a
great job
which is probably like a good thing to
do just in general i guess
it was just a kind of a futuristic cast
you know
and it was just working people because
women are always cold
[Laughter]
why they why there wouldn't be any women
in the [ __ ] arctic
no because back in those days we're just
joking that was the military yeah
antarctica would have
been military weather stations yeah and
it would have been
they would have been back then the
service was gendered
um let's see
and it's funny because actually i was
cold today in this room and hence why i
put long sleeves on
ventura okay now asking a question
ventura did he act as a military adviser
probably not
for for the predator because every one
of those guys was military
people forget that even arnold
schwarzenegger was a uh
he was a tanker from the austrian army
uh
the other two got the guys the other two
guys were vietnam veterans
uh jesse ventura was he was a seal but
he was a i think a reservist
i don't think he ever went active um
somebody might correct me on that but um
and uh maybe sonny i think sonny might
have been a veteran too but all those
guys were military if memory serves
thomas carlile said the 80s were good
for monster horror films at 70s was like
existential horror i agree i really
liked a lot of the
weird like haunted house or paranormal
type horror that came out of the 70s
but i mean 80s was great for monster
movies for horror comedies
for slashers for gore um all that kind
of [ __ ]
but as far as like i said i really i
like you know
creepy supernatural ghost story haunted
house kind of stuff that's kind of my
favorite sub genre i love gore films too
but so maybe i would kind of maybe have
to get the edge to the 70s but it's like
that it's
i don't know it's hard to pick because
so much good [ __ ] came out in the early
80s too
because it was like a spillover of
kanavatsalan he didn't know that
arnold was attacked yeah arnold arnold
was a he was an austrian
tanker i don't know if they were panzer
divisions probably not but tankers
he was he was a tanker driver i believe
yeah he told all kinds of stories about
[ __ ] up wrecking
wrecking not really wrecking tanks but
[ __ ] head guys
telling the story he told some stories
about what he did with tanks
um he did run he did get a little bit of
trouble because you know
he ran from the army to go do a uh
bodybuilding competition they wouldn't
let him go but he went anyway
he came back though they didn't do
anything to him but
uh you know pretty big for a tanker
it was a pretty big tank
the hatches are kind of small i know
what i'm talking about no i know i know
what it's
what a tank hatch looks like yeah uh
oracle says the little girl who lives
down the lane i have been wanting to
actually review that um on the show
because i
really really really like that movie and
i saw it a bunch of times like years and
years ago
and i have it on the list but i haven't
it keeps getting kind of
pusher i have so many movies on the list
you guys you don't even know
but that's definitely one of the ones
that's on there adults have you ever
seen it was jody foster when she was
a kid yeah it sounds familiar yeah it's
good it's creepy but yeah there's
another one that did kinky [ __ ] when she
was a kid didn't she play some [ __ ]
weird roles
jetty falls well she was a taxi driver
yeah that's right when she was a kid
playing an underage prostitute yeah i
don't think there was any nude
uh not that i remember i haven't seen
taxi driver in a while it was just brook
shields yeah pimping her out yeah there
was some mess-ups
back in those days i need to like i
remember like reading something about it
like a long time ago but yeah i think
that was
she had one of those weird showbiz moms
like yeah
hollywood was run by peter kratz creepy
yeah that's just [ __ ] crazy
i know all right but yeah so like i said
if you're into 80s horror
you got to see this [ __ ] no you don't
have to sit there and watch the whole
five hours at once like i did but
that's the thing you can choose you can
just watch a little bit at a time and
then go do something else and then come
back and watch it later
or you can just say [ __ ] it and do what
i did get a cocktail and sit there and
watch all [ __ ] five hours
and enjoy it immensely you know yeah
because that's
how you do but yeah it's on shutter like
i said get shutter if you don't have it
it's super good um they also just added
another
brand new movie which uh
we'll probably be talking about tomorrow
because i think i'm gonna watch it
tonight see how it is
um it looks like it's gotten pretty it's
called it's called host
okay nothing to do with like the korean
one about the monster
this is like a totally different it
looks like
um one of those online like
over skype horror movies it looks like
that but i'm not really sure
but it looks like it's gotten like
decent reviews okay so
we'll see how it shakes out i think i'll
watch that later tonight and see
and also we might watch the movie that
we're doing a retrospective on but i'm
not gonna
tell you what it is although if you're a
patron you already know because i posted
it on patreon yesterday
but i'm very excited about it because
i've been wanting to do this one for a
while
and uh yeah so uh i guess that'll do it
for
our sunday matinee yeah we'll see you
guys we'll see you guys later
yeah we'll uh live stream again tomorrow
probably about the same time
about three in the afternoon eastern
standard time so until tomorrow
thank you guys for stopping by bye